ladies how are you it's so good to see
you it's so good to see you and guess
what i also just had
you did it i can see you you could take
care of your eye surgery melissa you did
it i did it i don't need glasses anymore
kevin didn't want to
it changes your life we talked about
this i know i did it it changed your
mind it i swear to you
i'm like this i'm poor i'm looking at
you saying it wait but it it sounds like
melissa up there is that wait melissa
i'm i can't no i'm not that bad but i'm
headed okay i'm getting it done you all
have given me hope melissa you just did
the 40 by 40 campaign with meghan markle
which was pretty cool are we finally
getting matching tattoos i mean
well you know i already have something
really similar across my back this one's
you
and that one's me because sometimes i'm
like are we twinsies you know maybe we
save it for when i turn 50. what was
that like doing that just amazing she's
i'm impressed and inspired by her i love
someone who chooses to lead their life
the way they want to and give their
children the life that they they want to
give them and then to take an
opportunity where you know it's her 40th
may like what what fun thing does she
want and instead she's like how can i
get more people to help other women that
need help i was like that's that's what
we need we need a billion more people
like that in the world to do that to be
like take a little bit of time that you
can really help somebody she's like that
that's how i would like to celebrate my
40th and i was like
sign me up how do you not want to do
that i don't want to suffer
you're already suffering
both of you are funny as hell but you
played these two women who were going
through so much melissa what was it like
when you got to finally and i don't want
to give it away let that aggression out
you know it's cathartic it's cathartic
to play it
to be able to play it as myself because
i
i don't uh
physically lash out like that um
hopefully not many do but also it's the
character too i mean it was just
something you're like you
you know you have to do something it is
it's a scream in your backyard is it
whatever you have to do but it's like so
when something builds up
you gotta you have to put it somewhere
or else it just gets stuck back down
inside you and i think that's when the
damage really starts to grow in a person
so i love that it's like whatever
whatever
whichever way you need to
release things
it's i just thought it was a great thing
to be like it's not all the same and
it's okay if it's weird
she picked nine people who needed to be
in a place where they would try anything
she wanted
have you all gone mad
[Music]
regina um you also got to release things
but i just want to ask you about was
that a just crazy wig that they put on
your head as soon as you saw it you were
like this is a woman who's having
trouble
oh my goodness it's true that's how i
felt when i saw it it was perfect choice
it is yes when you see that you see a
woman who has lost a piece of herself a
little bit you know in self-care and
self everything
and so
i did love the choice for carmel because
i i felt like
um
you know what is it when someone doesn't
see you you know no one really
sees her and that and what that must
feel like to walk
would you ever would either one of you
ever try something like this micro
dosing regina you first
i would i mean i would prefer to know
you know i mean
as opposed to being like guess what um
but i think it's interesting finding you
know like hearing and you know studies
from way back you know way back to now
um um how wonderful these you know
treatments or methods have been they're
non-traditional and the breakthroughs
that so many people have had because of
them so i i mean i think it's a great
thing i i certainly i know if i were
carmella i'd try anything so i mean i
think it depends on where you're
starting but i think it's great when
people do that
under control and proper surface right
all right
melissa would you try it
uh
yes
yeah i mean that's like i i'm all for it
i think whatever like opens you up and
helps you
you know
kind of fight
search yourself a little i mean
i went to college things happened
it wasn't a controlled environment all
right i'm sorry behind the 7-11 hooked
us up i'm sorry kevin i want to ask her
that again what do what do you mean
melissa things happened you know you try
stuff
you swear that you can understand what
the dog's saying and uh
[Laughter]
regina i have one suggestion do you
think that melissa could go on the next
girls trip with y'all it would be so
amazing yes melissa could go on any trip
yeah and and maybe we'll end up behind a
7-eleven hearing what dogs are saying
sounds like she'd be a fun person to add
to the trip
but when regina drives me around
sometimes she makes me sit in the trunk
yeah it's not that great but yeah but
you know it's um it's a nice trunk
yeah it's a very nice trunk
i should move this through in the trunk
she put you in the trunk you know thanks
yeah that's all right i want you all now
to close your eyes
you wanna get well
you wanna heal
surrender yourself to me
i am gonna fix you how was it with
nicole's accent
was it like would it be cut and she'd go
back to the regular or did she stay in
the accent what was it like in it the
entire time
really yeah because she said she was
like oh yeah i can't she because i have
to stay in it because otherwise i'm
gonna you know i'll sound like an aussie
when i'm doing it so she would be like
she was really good about staying in it
which i i totally get she's like oh god
if i keep going back and forth i'll lose
my mind so you're just eating dinner and
she's like still speaking
and it didn't seem weird it's like it
didn't seem weird like yeah it's like
then when she you would hear her relax
and i was like oh god that's right how
was it being quarantined in australia
because melissa you came from working
with bobby you guys did your junket for
your other movie while you were in
quarantine in australia i know
it's like it's he's i've written him
into my contract no matter matter what
it is i'm like as long as cannavale's
involved um
the quarantining was crazy and something
that i feel like when i'm 90 somebody's
gonna be like what do you mean
quarantine it's like yeah i mean you got
put in a hotel room and by the military
and they said see in 15 days
don't screw up and you were like you got
it
i mean
it's also it uh it's a it's wild you
know you try to play dodgeball in a
hotel room with your kids so you don't
go crazy and
you go a little wacko
virginia
how was it for you regina
um i kind of liked it um
um in a weird way i was on the same
eating schedule as michael shannon we
would like open our door at the same
time
and like and be like uh oh are we
allowed to make eye contact there was a
there was like a guard
so when your door open you were like but
it was though it was um i watched i did
a lot of reading watch movies and then i
had um
i got a wonderful weird rash so it was
like it was a lot of
it was a lot of things but i have to say
it was really
it's a it's a it's a it's a real quiet
time to do a lot of reflection i will
say that melissa thank you again for
allowing me to see
i'm telling you get in it will change
all three of us will be like i see you
i know i'll be like look at every i
can't wait i'm
we talked about it already so i'm gonna
do it melissa's the one who saved me i
couldn't i was like trying to read my
cards and she was like what's wrong with
you it's like i can't see a damn thing
she was like go see this guy now like go
back 10 feet
and literally she said go see this guy
next thing i know i'm in his office boom
bang boom he slices my eyes open i'm
better man
i mean i wish you would have phrased it
better i was like i don't know that you
need to say slice before someone's
thinking about doing it um it's a very
precise procedure yeah yeah while you're
awake ladies thanks it's always great
seeing y'all hopefully i get to see you
in person soon
[Music]